[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN: Hey
there, everybody.
Todd Kerpelman here at
the Accessibility section
of the Sandbox.
And I am joined by Patrick
Clary, who is a product
manager here at Google.
Hi, Patrick.
PATRICK CLARY: Hi,
how's it going?
TODD KERPELMAN: It's
going pretty well.
So tell us what's going on here
at the Accessibility Sandbox.
PATRICK CLARY: Yeah.
So in the Sandbox, we're
doing various things.
We're showing demos of Liftware.
We're showing off some of our
wheelchair accessible transit
directions we have
in Google Maps.
We're showing off our automated
captioning for YouTube.
We're doing accessibility
design reviews over here.
And we're also showing a brand
new product, which we announced
yesterday, called Lookout.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh.
And what is Lookout?
Tell me more about that.
PATRICK CLARY: So Lookout
is a product for users
who are blind and low vision.
And the goal is to
help them become
aware of physical objects in the
space around them, for example,
people that might be present,
a text in their environment,
and also physical
objects or products.
TODD KERPELMAN: Can we see a
demo of Lookout, telling us
what's in our environment?
PATRICK CLARY:
Yeah, let's do that.
So I have the app here.
And I'll go ahead
and select the icon.
And then for this, I'll
select an experimental mode
because that's
kind of fun, right?
And we'll see what it shows.
SPEAKER 3: (ON PHONE)
Drink with text NB18 NOND.
[INAUDIBLE]
PATRICK CLARY: So it
detected some text on that,
and it read it out.
As you can see, it
said Murphy, which is
the brand of wine we have here.
Let me point it at this
glass and see what it does.
SPEAKER 3: (ON PHONE)
Wine glass at 12 o'clock.
TODD KERPELMAN: So what else
can you do with Lookout?
PATRICK CLARY: Well,
what's interesting
about Lookout is it's
designed to basically be worn.
So we can put it in
a lanyard like this.
And this allows the user
to be hands-free and just
engage in their activity.
And there's controls
that facilitate this.
So for example, if I want
to start recognition,
I can knock on the device.
And then if I want
to pause recognition,
I can cover the camera.
There we go.
TODD KERPELMAN: And if
I'm interested in trying
Lookout, where would
I be able to get it?
PATRICK CLARY: Yeah, So we'll be
rolling out to trusted testers
pretty soon here.
And you can go to
google.com/accessibility
to sign up for a
trusted tester spot.
And then later this
year, we'll be pushing it
to the Play Store.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
so be on the lookout.
Ha, see what I did there?
I said look.
Be on the lookout for
Lookout coming soon
to a Play Store near you.
Thank you, very much,
Patrick, for the tour.
PATRICK CLARY:
Yeah, my pleasure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]